Despite El Camino's efforts to provide closure
for some of Breaking Bad's few lingering questions,
there are still a few loose ends remaining
at the end.
Here are all the biggest questions that we're
still asking after El Camino: A Breaking Bad
Movie.
Although Walt's wife Skyler spent the first
couple seasons of Breaking Bad unaware of
his illegal dealings, she eventually joined
him on the dark side when she began helping
Walt to launder his money.
By the end of the series, the pragmatic Skyler
was up to her ears in illicit activity, adding
tax fraud and obstruction of justice to her
crimes, in addition to suggesting that Walt
have Jesse Pinkman killed.
"You need to deal with this."
"How much have you had to drink?"
"Not nearly enough."
In the finale, Walt gave Skyler a lottery
ticket with the coordinates for the location
where the bodies of Hank Schrader and Steve
Gomez were buried, thinking she could trade
the information for immunity.
However, that's the last we ever see of Skyler,
and El Camino never mentions what became of
her.
We have no way of knowing whether Walt's last
attempt to help his family paid off, or whether
the bodies of two dead DEA agents wasn't a
big enough bargaining chip to get Skyler off
the hook for her criminal misdeeds.
Realizing that every penny he ever made selling
meth would likely get seized by the DEA once
they finished amassing evidence against him,
Walt decides to get his money to his family
via a more circuitous route.
Visiting the luxurious home of his former
business partners, Elliott and Gretchen Schwartz,
Walt gives them the $9.72 million he'd managed
to hold onto after the rest of his fortune
was seized by Uncle Jack and his gang of white
supremacists.
He instructs them to set up a trust for his
son, Walt Jr., which will be given to him
on his 18th birthday as a gift from the Schwartzes.
Walt then threatens them that if they fail
to carry out his instructions, he has hired
assassins to have them killed.
However, Walt Jr.'s birthday was still ten
months away at the end of "Felina," and El
Camino leaves us with no way of knowing whether
the Schwartzes carried out their end of the
bargain.
We do know that Walt's "assassins" were actually
just Badger and Skinny Peter with laser pointers,
so there wouldn't be any consequences if the
Schwartzes decided to keep the money.
Whether Gretchen and Elliot figured that out,
though, we may never know.
After Hank discovers the truth about Walt
and arrests him, his wife Marie seems to relish
forcing her sister to tell Walt Jr. the truth
about Walt.
However, Marie climbs off her high horse to
support her sister when Walt captures baby
Holly, only to be devastated again when she
learns that Hank is killed.
The last contact we see between Marie and
Skyler is in the finale, when Marie calls
to warn Skyler that Walt is back in town,
and cautions her to stay wary and safe.
"On the million to one chance, you be on the
lookout okay?"
It's implied during that conversation that
the sisters haven't spoken in months.
While the relationship between Sklyer and
Marie wasn't always the best, they seemed
fairly close in the early seasons, living
nearby and seeing each other often.
It's probably safe to assume that their relationship
will never be the same following the finale.
However, we'll never see whether their relationship
continued to heal or was severed for good,
since neither sister is seen or mentioned
in El Camino.
In "Felina," Walter White spends a lot of
time paying back the people who have wronged
him, but one of his most elaborate revenge
schemes involves his judgement on Lydia Rodarte-Quayle
. Lydia tries to conspire against Walt when
he comes back to town, but Walt is several
steps ahead, and uses her own habits against
her by poisoning the Stevia she always used
in her tea.
The last we saw Lydia, she was looking significantly
under the weather when she called Todd, thinking
that her plan to kill Walt had been successfully
carried out.
Soon after, Walt tells her that not only had
her plan failed, but that her illness was
in fact the first stages of ricin poisoning.
While Breaking Bad implied that Lydia was
doomed, El Camino reveals that her fate may
still be up in the air.
At one point, Jesse hears a radio news report
that mentions a "Houston woman" with possible
ties to Walter White is in the hospital in
critical condition and not expected to survive.
However, while her odds don't look great,
we'll never know for sure if Walt was successful
in his attempt to get rid of her.
“Well, bye Lydia.”
One of the most heartwarming parts of El Camino
comes right at the beginning, when a traumatized
Jesse turns to two of the only allies he has
left his longtime friends Skinny Pete and
Badger.
However, after Pete and Badger help Jesse,
they hit a snag when they attempt to get rid
of the El Camino that Jesse was driving: the
LoJack was activated, meaning the police will
arrive at Pete's house soon.
Jesse offers to drive the El Camino away from
the house, but Skinny Pete has another plan:
Badger will abandon Pete's car near the Mexican
border, Jesse will escape in Badger's car,
and Pete will remain at his house with the
El Camino.
Pete and Badger also give Jesse all the money
they have on them.
After Jesse and Badger drive off, Pete moves
the El Camino to the front of his driveway
and waits for the police to arrive, showing
that he has nothing to hide.
While the teaser for El Camino seemed to pick
up after this with Pete in the police station,
the film itself never shows either of Jesse's
friends again.
We can only hope that Pete and Badger get
to go home and keep working on their Star
Trek spec script.
"I ever tell you about my Star Trek script?"
"Star Trek?"
"Yeah, I gotta write it down is all.
The enterprise…"
In the penultimate scene of El Camino, as
Jesse prepares to embark on his new life in
Alaska, Ed the Disappearer asks him if there's
anything else Jesse needs to take care of
before the two part ways.
Jesse hands him a letter which Ed reads over
and then promises to mail from Mexico City
in a month.
As Jesse drives away, the camera reveals that
the letter is addressed to Brock Cantillo.
Neither of them discusses what Jesse wrote
in his final missive to Brock, although we
can guess that at least part of his note was
a farewell.
The rest is left up to our imaginations.
Perhaps Jesse tried to offer some sort of
explanation or apology for what happened to
his mother.
It's also possible that Jesse used some of
the money he took from Neil Kandy to help
provide for Brock's future, similar to the
trust Walt managed to set up for his son.
We may never know what Jesse's final words
to Brock were, but no matter what he wrote,
we're sure it came from the heart.
The last we saw of Saul Goodman's intimidating
bodyguard Huell Babineaux toward the end of
Breaking Bad, he was sitting in a DEA safehouse,
patiently awaiting the return of Hank Schrader
and Steve Gomez.
Unfortunately for everyone, Hank and Steve
were killed by Jack Welker and his gang shortly
thereafter, so they wouldn't ever return to
the safehouse to advise Huell on next steps.
According to series creator Vince Gilligan,
Huell would have eventually been found, questioned,
and ultimately released by other DEA agents.
But that's not really good enough for fans
who hoped to see Huell's fate definitively
addressed in canon.
The official Breaking Bad Facebook page took
it one step further, sharing a video of Huell
getting up and leaving the safe house to coincide
with the release of El Camino.
Still, Huell failed to get a cameo, or even
a mention, in the movie itself.
Even if we consider the Facebook video part
of the film, all it establishes is that Huell
eventually left the safe house.
We have no idea where he went or what he's
up to now, and El Camino doesn't give us any
clues.
The other long-suffering employee in the office
of Saul Goodman & Associates is Francesca
Liddy, who we last saw toward the end of Breaking
Bad's final season, when she was held at gunpoint
by Jesse Pinkman.
Although Huell was later picked up by the
DEA, we never learn what became of Francesca
after Saul fled Albuquerque and Saul Goodman
& Associates was no more.
In the Breaking Bad spinoff series Better
Call Saul, we learn that Francesca was once
a bright-eyed and enthusiastic former employee
of New Mexico's Motor Vehicle Division.
Somehow, over her years of working with Saul,
she became jaded and cynical.
We wondered whether we might see her pop up
in El Camino, but the former receptionist/accomplice
didn't receive a mention in the Jesse-centric
tale.
We're not sure what professional opportunities
are out there for a secretary who spent the
last decade of her life working for a shady
criminal lawyer who's currently wanted by
the DEA.
Still, Better Call Saul did leave us with
a few clues for where Francesca goes after
the events of Breaking Bad.
In the spinoff, we see that Saul gives Francesca
the business card of a lawyer from his Jimmy
McGill days we may find out what happened
to Francesca in an upcoming season of BCS.
For viewers of Better Call Saul, we've gotten
a small glimpse into what Saul Goodman, formerly
known as Jimmy McGill, is up to following
the events of Breaking Bad.
The last we saw him in Breaking Bad, Saul
was preparing to embark on a new life in Nebraska,
courtesy of Ed the Disappearer.
In Better Call Saul, we see that in his new
life, Saul is known as Gene, and he works
at a Cinnabon in Omaha.
Still afraid of the enemies he made through
his association with Walt, Gene lives in a
constant state of anxiety and paranoia.
While we may eventually get a more complete
picture of what Saul's life looks like following
Breaking Bad, El Camino didn't offer up any
clues.
The only obscure nod to Saul Goodman is a
brief shot of the strip mall that once housed
his law office, which has since been turned
into a sports bar.
Neither Jesse nor Ed ever discusses what became
of the disgraced former lawyer, and although
Better Call Saul fills in the blanks a little
bit, there's still plenty we don't know about
Saul's life following Breaking Bad.
But if there's one thing we know about Saul
Goodman, it's that as much as he may insist
he's left his former life behind him, he won't
be able to keep his nose clean for long.
Throughout Breaking Bad, although it was never
stated outright, it was always implied that
Jesse Pinkman dropped out of high school before
graduating.
We knew that he failed Mr. White's chemistry
class as a junior, yet Jesse's parents still
considered Walt one of Jesse's better teachers,
implying that his F in chemistry was not an
anomaly on his report card.
However, in El Camino, Walt comments that
Jesse might try college, suggesting a business
and marketing degree as a counter to Jesse's
proposal of sports medicine.
But first, Walt says, Jesse would have to
get his GED, to which Jesse responds that
he doesn't need a GED because he already has
a high school diploma.
"Yo, you were standing right on stage when
they handed it to me."
"It just slipped my mind."
"I totally graduated high school, dick."
Of course, now that Jesse has a new identity
in Alaska as "Mr. Driscoll," he likely wouldn't
be using his degree from J.P. Wynne High School
on his application, but that doesn't mean
he can't continue his education under his
new name.
If Jesse Pinkman has a completed high school
education, then so does Mr. Driscoll, and
although few of Walter White's ideas ever
seemed to be in Jesse's best interest, this
one might be.
El Camino doesn't tell us what happens to
Jesse once he arrives in Alaska, but it's
nice to think that if we were to catch up
with him at some point in the distant future,
we'd find him with a successful career in
sports medicine.
If not that, maybe he can major in...
"Magnets!
Oh!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.